henry rollins is best known for being
the lead vocalist of hardcore punk band
black flag which made him
one of the most recognizable faces in
the 1980s punk scene he went from being
diagnosed with hyperactivity
dropping out of school working minimum
wage jobs to becoming a punk
icon actor and a highly paid radio show
host
need motivation watch your top 10 with
believe nation
top 10
all my life
hey it's evan carl michael and i make
these videos because you are probably
the most ambitious person that you know
but you also know that you're capable of
more and you get that push by
surrounding yourself with the best so
today let's learn from one of the best
henry rollins and my take on his top 10
rules of success
enjoy okay let's kick it off with rule
number one seek
opportunities i'm a crass opportunist
and that i'm really not good at any of
the stuff i do
i'm a jackass of all tirades
when i i was doing music at some point
in the 80s hollywood director started
calling me
hey you're that crazy guy can you act
i'm like yeah can you pay
because i i i this top ramen
noodle diet's killing me i'll try
anything
and so i started my own little
publishing company in the 80s to write
my dumb little books
and i stayed with it started doing the
talking shows stayed with that
at one point hey you want to do a
voiceover yeah i'll put my voice over
anything
over rice over noodles and over your
over your ad
and so i say yes to stuff because why
not
and so i just go running at things and
so what am i
i'm not only am i an american but i i'm
an americanist
and not really a survivalist as much as
one who seeks to prevail
and i i think one of the things i
luckily
guys like me have to do everything three
times before we get it right
thankfully i know that so i know that i
have to get up early and and try it five
times
because the eight-year-old will be able
to get past it in two times so i have to
be on my feet longer but at least i know
it and so i just go at stuff
and it served me very well and that my
resume is pretty varied
and uh i have a pretty interesting life
yeah i get to do different stuff and
have a bit of access
because i just said yeah i'll try that i
mean
why would i hold back rule number two
set up adversarial relationships
what powers me it's not money it's not
ambition
it's anger i'm one of those people i i
i wish was a better way to say it but i
i it's it's
vengeance you laughed at me in high
school man you said i was going to be
anything
really like watch this like that's
still pushing you at 56. i hate to say
it oh yeah
40 40 years later oh yeah all of it like
you know
my dad you know he was a big money guy
i'm like okay
you love money so much watch me out
gross you and your whole damn family
to combined and i don't even care about
it i just like achieving it
and it's one of the reasons when the
agent goes okay
five shows on one off i'm like oh no no
man no no that's a day off you put a
show in there
like why because like screw that man
watch me do
put two shows on that night well you
think i can't i'm just
like i said i set up adversarial
relationships i'm not against you or
anything
i'm just saying like i have to have
something to push against like a
schedule that there's like
the schedules like godzilla like you
can't
finish this like really man i'm gonna
serve you up and eat you
every day like a steak and i just have
to have that and so i'm getting back
and it's i think of all the people i was
in bands with i have to crush
them everyone i grew up with i have to
powderize them that's such a weird
motivation
it sucks it's immature it's like it's 11
year old sandbox wow
you're aware of it yeah that which makes
it even stranger
because it's not something that you're
just operating under well you know you
have it's
it's controlling you and you don't
understand i quite enjoy it
yeah yeah like if i you know i
i'm not an actor but i go up for acting
parts so i'm like basically
going in there and winging it and i get
you know i get to go up for like really
big parts there's a little bit of
trepidation
knowing i'm going in there but then i
think like oh yeah
sony whatever man line it up
and i almost like run out of my car like
you know where are you at man
and i'm not trying to impress you i'm a
tough guy because i'm not i just need to
it just needs to be trying to tell me i
can't
and i it that informs that
everything i do like instead of just
dialing my radio show in i work on that
sucker for like five hours
it has to be all hand-picked now that
song not that one this one
and i make like three drafts of it it's
intense it's one of the reasons why i
live alone
is like i work all the time like hey
come out on this weekend no i'm it's 7
p.m on a friday i'm working
like i'm not i'm not constant yeah
no i'm not fun to hang out with do you
vacation ever where you just chill no i
i can't
intellectually and existentially i can't
understand the idea of a vacation
i i make a joke on stage i said i want
to come back 10 pounds lighter with an
internal parasite
i i i want to come back with like a scar
where the spear kind of grazed me
and eight great stories and a dangerous
insect in my bag
i don't want to sit on the beach and
soak in the rays
i want to get sunburned by you know
being in the desert
and like you know figuring out how the
sun won't try and kill me by noon
that's the sahara and so that's how i go
about it
so part of your motivation is actually
the perception by other people of what
you're doing
like understanding that what you're
doing is so undeniable
the volume that you're putting out and
the intensity yeah the intensity so
undeniable
like i'll show you yeah absolutely wow
that's so weird even with people who
like me
like yay henry's here i'm like yeah i'm
here check it out this out
yeah here's a place you won't go and
it's not that i have any aggression
towards these people i just
i just want to burn brightly yeah and
it's not about money
it's it's not about i'm better than you
because i i don't think i'm better than
anybody
i just want to explode as much as
possible
and i think to my audience it's to their
benefit he's like that dude's gonna go
out there to a place i don't wanna go
he's gonna come back with 10 great
photos
and a story about how he really lost his
foot it's great
and like put me in coach that's the game
i want to play that's what i go for rule
number three
learn from your past do you spend more
time thinking about the future
or the past the future why is that
because i want it
because the past holds all of your
mistakes and humiliations
the future holds whatever you can make
it and so the past has already been
determined
it also holds all your victories and all
your accomplishments but all the bad
stuff is there too so why dwell
learn from it and move on don't ignore
it and don't say it didn't happen don't
deny it
but don't you don't have to dwell on it
and be miserable uh that happens enough
to us adults
already you you see someone from your
past like ah it still
hurts but the future is ready for you to
not make those mistakes and to make it
great
now that i have less future than i do
past
i seek to make because i'm well over the
50-yard line of mortality
at 55. you know there's no way i'm
getting 110 out of this
uh i don't know you never know you seem
pretty energetic
well it might just burn me out but
knowing i have less in front of me than
behind me why not
be cool with it don't i'm gonna die soon
like oh look you've got some time left
rock out like like make it amazing where
the past has been done
rule number four always bring your a
game
best part about talking on stage
people listen and they trust you and so
you get to have that great weight of
responsibility to not mess it up and not
waste their time
or let them down or do them wrong what's
the worst part about talking
on stage uh
not not trusting your material enough to
really
be confident in it happened to me many
years ago for like a week
so i took care of that never want to go
back there again yeah i think that's the
nature of
of performance performers feel that way
a lot yeah well yeah
there's a lot of people who are really
talented and then they'll they'll assure
you that every show they've ever done
they bombed and you're like no you were
great no no that was awful like
actually you killed it that was great no
i'm bad
i call it serving up thin broth you
never want to go on stage with thin
broth
and so i work very hard at going on
stage with if i'm going to be slinging
intellectual hash
on stage to my wonderful audience who i
love obsessively
i can never bring them anything less
than my a-game
and in in material that i must work
and go through pain to get so you want a
story about travel
i'm going to go to north korea and tell
you about my time in pyongyang which i
did do
and so if i tell a travel story i did
get the big fish and here it is it
didn't get away so i don't tell you well
oh the last time i went to buffalo which
is wonderful
i go to buffalo and tell you about the
time i went to afghanistan
and so i work hard to come back with
great topics and subjects that i endured
to bring back the story also if you want
to have unstoppable confidence and
self-love check out my 254 series
they're free
the links are joined on the description
below i'm not exactly quitting
but here's this thing that happened and
he said it's your shot
i said yeah he said take it what are you
doing tomorrow eight o'clock on stage
we're doing the night after i'll be on
stage
what about two months from now i'll be
still on that same tour rule number five
figure out who you are you get as a
young adult you start to figure out who
you are
and i go okay i'm not an artist but i'm
an artist type
i'm i'm nuts you can't put me in a
straight job i can pass for normal just
because i can task it
i can totally do it like you can put me
in a ralph's a kroger's
a starbucks i will totally get in there
and hit the work and clean it all and
serve it up
with a smile but i'll be going crazy
inside
i will be punching everybody in those
places is going crazy inside
i don't know but um i can't sustain in
that
and i haven't had to for many years i've
been lucky i've been
in the world of lunatics since 1981 yeah
being a crazy person out with other
crazy people
and when i look at a straight job i'm
like man
i don't think at this point i could hack
it not because i'm spoiled
just because i've never had to tether my
adult mind
to that i work seven days a week but on
henry's stuff
yeah it's me it's not it's a different
thing it's a different thing
yeah you enjoy that work yeah and it's
it's way over 60 hours a week
rule number six employee discipline and
stamina
i do a lot of book writing i own the
book publishing company on prolific
because i sleep with the owner every
night
and so um i have two books coming up
this year a project that started in
2013. it's like over
over half a million words i've worked on
this series of music books
the first one is it layout the next one
i'm editing for the seventh time
uh books like it's like a four year
idea i come up with the idea like wow
five years from now i'm still going to
be
grinding this thing out so you learn to
have a long range idea of the finishing
of the product
and i encourage any of you when i have
these ideas i'm not telling you what to
do i wouldn't dare
but i would advise to employ a lot of
discipline
and stamina to get any project done you
want to get your studio finished to do
voice over
podcasting get a recording studio
together your recording artist
it's not fast and it's not easy
so you have to be ready to lose all your
friends live on top ramen noodles sleep
on the floor
have bugs in your hair and just do it
yourself
and like lose the girlfriend lose all
your friends and be well you're trying
to you're trying to get the gold
medal of the olympics you're going to
beat the other person by a fraction of a
second
and so you have to have tenacity
discipline
and you have to be a little crazy now
and then and just like
that's never going to work oh it'll work
i'm going to force it until it until you
like me i'm gonna do it
and so you have to have some of that
rule number seven don't
procrastinate secret talent
uh great ability to procrastinate you do
you do that a lot i
i i put things off and it's secret
because i don't tell anyone like
have you gotten this and i'm right on it
i'm on the case it's done
i better get to work on that and i can
turn it around faster than i thought
so fear of failure but i will put things
off so and i don't i don't like that
about myself i'm getting better
but i will procrastinate so what do you
do while you're procrastinating worry
and go i really should be doing this and
then suddenly i'm doing it
rule number eight live to achieve i had
a
uh this this coach he's mentioned in
that article that you were talking about
the iron i talked about mr peppermint
yeah and he is he he i was in his car
pool he was a vietnam vet
and uh he once said to me i i have to
quote he
said uh you're a skinny little gee thank
you sir
and uh he said i'm gonna teach you how
to lift weights i said okay it's more
attention than my dad gave me so i said
i'll take it
and so he taught me compound lifts at
the school gym so i bought a sears and
robux sand filled weight set which i
couldn't drag to my mom's station uh vw
fastback and eventually i did uh by
three months of that weight set i'm
fairly throwing it across the room
because you know you're growing so fast
like your muscles are recovering
overnight you just do the same workout
every day you don't even feel it
and he said you're not allowed to look
at yourself until christmas break after
christmas exams and this was like in
september so i didn't i did everything
he told me to
and then he dropped me off before the
christmas break he said
now today you can look at yourself in
the mirror and i ran home
like ran home and i tore my stupid
school uniform off and i stood in the
mirror
and my body had definition i'm like wow
those are pecs those i mean like i
looked like i was a guy who lifted some
weights
and i it was self-validating like wow
i'm here
i did that i'm looking at myself going i
did that
no one can lift those weights for you
and the feeling of achievement it gave
me
that i accomplished that was
a shot in the arm that i still feel to
this day wow
i mean because it was so like wow you
can do this that's
possible right because every other time
trying to meet girls at the
school dance i had no guts to talk to
the girls so they were alien creatures
um i didn't do well in school so you
could make fun of me i couldn't throw
the ball straight
so they would throw it at my head to
watch me run and so i
it didn't have any traction anywhere and
then when i had the weights i'm like wow
i i'm filling out my t-shirt man
noticeable improvement hell yeah i mean
plus effort
equals results and i couldn't didn't
make my grades better because i still it
was all
of swahili to me is schooling was a slip
too it was probably too late
i just yeah i was not good at sitting
still
but when i had the summer jobs that's
when i kicked ass
i never had an allowance i never my mom
said you never said here's 20 bucks i'm
like where'd henry go he's got three
jobs over the weekend
i'd wake up in the morning go to the pet
shop work all day there
run home shower change my clothes do the
night shift at the movie theater
take the bus out to the surf shop in the
suburbs and
repair skateboards and whatever on
sundays so i always had
pocket money because i was i liked
having working a cash register
on my keychain in school i had the keys
to stores
bosses trusted me because i'd never
steal and i
so i would work like like 20 hours a
week and go to school
in high school and part of that was
informed by the weightlifting and
i like getting out of the house and
being responsible but in school it
didn't mean much to me but
showing up on time at the pet shop and
cleaning out 20 cat pans man that was
like
i had to be there at 8 o'clock not 801
man
because we got things to do i felt a
real fealty
and to this day like if i'm ever on a
film shoot like who's the guy who's
there early man that's me i'm i'm there
i memorized the whole damn script
i'm so happy to have a job i'm like
amazed anyone cares
and so all of that uh it keeps me on the
straight and narrow because i i
i call myself a human frozen yogurt
machine just output
you know i don't want the applause i
don't i like to build chips i don't want
to sail in them
and the best part about finishing the
ship is it sails off to sea and you can
build another
so i love finishing a book you know i'll
get this thing off my desktop
now i can start a new one like where can
i go now
and so that's how i i live to achieve
and to output but it's not i don't
ever look at i have a thing on my
computer
it's called the list and i keep a list
of like every show
every book i've written every movie i've
been in every album i've ever made and
when you look at it
it's intense it's like you keep a list
of every show you've ever done oh hell
yeah of course
wow of course i don't know anybody who
does that yeah and
and sometimes i write down uh the set
length
i take a lot of notes wow oh yeah write
them all down but um
i have this one thing called the list
and it's just like you know every film
every tv show every voiceover
um every book every record on on and on
and sometimes i look at it just because
i have to input like the new book comes
out i have to go to the thing and input
and i look at this list and my bones
start aching
i'm like man this is a lot of there's a
lot of a lot of crap this came out yeah
and i don't wave it around and go see
what i've done i just kind of go i'm
only interested in what i'm doing what
i'm doing next
rule number nine love what you're doing
miles davis said music should not
not leave a mark on the person doing it
like you should leave the stage empty
saturn
like don't go for the low hanging fruit
rock and roll broke my body to pieces i
got so many
stitches and concussions my back is i
mean
i gave it everything and i paid
so i would advise intensity tenacity
and you gotta love what you're doing and
you can't love the money or the fame
because it rarely
there'll be any or either you just have
to love what you're doing
and love it harder than you look kind of
loved anything else
and rule number 10 the last one before a
very special bonus clip
is have fun and last year i had four
days off between a show in spain
and a show in portugal and the show in
portugal i knew was going to be my last
day
on earth why because we were opening for
iron maiden
okay
right iron maiden there's a legion of
fans like these gentlemen over here
okay if you are in front of 18 to 20 000
iron maiden fans
the upside is they only want to see one
band
the downside is you are not in that band
you are the irritant they
hate your guts they have it in their
minds what little
minds they have
see shake your head a little i want to
hear it oh my god knock around inside
the crate
anyway only kidding only kidding but you
know how you guys are you want
murdered and when the opening ban is on
wagons believe me i've been there i've
done it
i survived it you know my back still
hurts
and anyway so you have these people made
and made
well uh we're not iron maiden but boy we
sure can play a tune
you don't like us and they have it in
their mind that if you weren't on stage
iron maiden would be that if you weren't
playing from 805 to 845
iron maiden would have been there at
eight o'clock so they figure if you
weren't there
you know basically you're just blocking
them from
maiden and picture
the the mindset of an iron maiden fan at
an iron maiden gig they've been waiting
for this gig for weeks they've been
looking at the ticket every day to make
sure the ink does not fall off the piece
of paper
they keep reading it every day still
says iron maiden okay cool
cool does not say bjorn again it says
iron maiden we are going to see
maiden and they play every maiden record
over and over every iron maiden bootleg
they are wearing the shirts they are
psyched
and there's some opening band day today
we're not iron maiden hey
if you've ever seen interviews with iron
maiden your hero pal
bruce dickinson that oh yeah he's a
mental colossus isn't he he's just
fantastic
yeah right man we wrote uh we write
songs about books we've read wrong
i mean we're not stupid man we don't
write songs about like cars and girls
and whatnot
we write songs about real things like
books like a song we wrote called rahm
of the ancient mayor in iran
alone alone all alone alone on a wide
wide sea
hey you know it's about a bloke with an
albatross around his neck
sailing about so we wrote the song about
a bloke on a boat
with a bird around his neck going i'm so
alone wrong because sometimes you're
walking about with a bird around your
neck
or it feels like a bird around your neck
and you go
hey man i'm so alone right so we wrote
that song for you right because we're
always thinking wrong
we wrote this song called flight of
icarus it's about it's a fable it's a
fable
it's about this bloke named icarus wrong
and one day he goes
hello i think i'm gonna go fly about so
he builds
he builds some wings out of wax and
feathers right and he goes flying about
like a [ __ ] through the air right and it
goes up to this rumored ball of fire
called the sun that hides obscured by
the clouds over the uk right
so he goes up to the room with ball of
fire and the wings melt because it made
out of wax right so he goes plummeting
plummeting down to the earth and he
dies right all right so we wrote this
song called flood of icarus rock
and it's basically saying hey man wake
up don't go flying about near the sun
unless you're in an airplane right
because the wings the wings are metal
right and they won't melt right
so here's a song that's working on two
different levels
two different levels at once right no no
check it out check it out because
the wings of the plane are made out of
metal right and we play
metal music right right so the song is
coming at you here as well as here right
so the song is basically doing like
right two-dimensional right see so
maiden's always
thinking always thinking and so
when you're when you're in front of like
18 000 people who want two and a half
hours of that
they're gonna kill you because they have
radar and they can pick up the wise ass
in any band
kill henry kill henry kill henry rip him
from
him and so i know i'm gonna die
now i've got a special bonus gift from
henry on how to take care of your body
that i think you're gonna enjoy but
before that it's time for the question
of the day i want to know
where do you need to stop
procrastinating
let me know put it down in the comments
below and if you made it this far in a
video you're still here watching
give me a hashtag believe down the
comments below
i want to celebrate you we don't just
watch videos here
we do something about it so give me that
believe in the comments below
too now a little bit later in life
how do you see the relationship between
the mind and the body and the creative
process
are you all one it has to be for me
and i'm not trying to sound like your
yoga instructor
but for me mind and body it's almost
more of a martial arts idea
where the physicality is attached to a
thought
and the thought is attached to
physicality that's acting that's acting
class that's every day in acting class
attach the movement to the emotion
action
be the be the crazy guy whatever and so
for me
when i would tour with music i'm not a
musician as much as i'm an nba player
so me and the drummer of bill stevenson
who you know from the descendants
bill and i would go out and run for two
hours a night after band practice we're
20 something we can do it
and so for me touring was three months
of training and diet so
by the time we're doing the first show
it's the start of the season for me
so i train athletically for tours i
eat one to one and a half meals a day
and i train
three days on one day off and i'm 57 i
mean
i still train like this i'm not touring
this year i just finished drawing from
last year
and this is how i i am
because i can't do my work unless my
body's humming and if it so it's a
specific diet
sleep regimen lots of water i don't
smoke or drink
but my thoughts aren't good if my body's
not good
i can't have one without i can't divorce
the two
i can't have a body that's not working
and have the brain work
and i need the whole thing to work
because i said yes to a bunch of stuff
which i now have to fulfill
[Music]
hey if you want more top 10 rules videos
they are no longer on this channel i
have a dedicated brand new channel just
for them
if you want to check it out go subscribe
the link is right there next to me
lots of great content go there go check
it out and continue to believe
and i'll see you there